1993 20 years ago this summer Nintendo
and Ueno Vista audaciously merged a
video game platform in the silver screen
with Super Mario Brothers this game the
first cinematic adaptation of a video
game property with a 50 million dollar
budget in a tone bearing little
resemblance to the actual game the film
never captivated fans of the series or
movie going audiences over the next two
decades nothing much has changed it's no
secret that video game adaptations have
had a rough history on the silver screen
out of over 30 major motion pictures
based on a video game properties that
have come out since Super Mario Brothers
so far none have amassed a fresh rotten
tomato rating in fact the highest rated
movie based on a game is 2001 s Final
Fantasy the spirit with the oh my god
that only have 44 percent so it begs the
question why well there are many number
of reasons and everyone has their own
opinion we have our own feelings and
wild failures of the past offer lessons
for the future this video is strictly
about the road ahead so here's our case
for why audiences and Studios alike
should be excited for a second chance
with the market growing as fast as the
technology video games have had to
advance the ability and telling
compelling stories especially in a time
full of rich media on every platform
competing for an audience just as a
plumber jumping on mushrooms with a big
leak in two rectangles and a ball
developers have been competing with the
spectacle of blockbusters of these
stories of HBO in an ever expanding
campus and you know what it's working
compared the Cormac McCarthy s The Last
of Us and the Marc Forster epic thriller
World War Z most audiences and gamers
found one as viably compelling and rich
as the other in fact many found the last
of us to be a stronger narrative story
is important more and more developers
are hiring a less screen writers such as
Academy award-winning Stephen Gaghan who
just penned the next Call of Duty a win
for Hollywood would be to do the exact
opposite why not merge the creative team
of the video game and the filmmakers for
the movie project in order to unify a
property as opposed to simply licensing
the property without any input from the
create
it was obvious just take a look at the
renowned developer valve and their Team
Fortress 2 short films tell me these
aren't as good as anything coming out of
Pixar top developers have been coding
this idea in the past few years Rockstar
teamed with acclaimed filmmaker John
Hill Coates and make an excellent Red
Dead Redemption short and at this year's
dice event JJ Abrams and valve CEO Gabe
Newell announced interest in working
together this was a winning tactic when
Marvel Studios joined Disney and put
creative heads of the comics like Jeff
lobe in charge of the feature film and
television divisions this game designer
can dream up a character give him a
personality lifelike moves and quickly
bring his paper sketches to life with
the advance and facial performance
technology came the necessity to
incorporate nuance and characters a
decade ago the selling points for the
film adaptations of games were primarily
set around set pieces monsters and plot
while actors were regulated - well more
or less just how they look today's
performances are key to the appeal of
triple a time you guys seen this already
Gary Oldman Sam Jackson Liam Neeson
Patrick Stewart Kiefer Sutherland and
Mark Strong are just a few a list names
who have lent their voices to popular
videogame characters we have trouble
claw together additionally Ellen Page
and William Dafoe went the extra mile on
performing motion capture recording for
beyond 2 souls just this year further
blurring the line between cinematic
experience and the video game experience
you're out on your get it's becoming a
serious medium for Testament so much
that the name nolan north from the last
of us uncharted and batman will draw
just as much attention on the comic-con
Florez say Harrison Ford which is a
pretty recent phenomenon once a
developer creates a vivid engine the
possibility of expansive set pieces are
limited more to the imagination than the
dollar
unlike films for the past decade a good
deal of popular game titles have been
attempting to reflect classic cinematic
set pieces from Scarface and heat in
Grand Theft Auto two Uncharted dazzling
Indiana Jones like presentation video
games typically gain appeal and
nostalgia reconstruction of blockbusters
now looking at a game like total war
Rome - it's safe to say the other side
of the aisle can get just as inspired
with the technical canvas expanding
every generation artists and designers
have continually redefined and
reimagined the scale and the detail
required to convince Lee immerse the
players into the story they are telling
George Lucas couldn't ask for the kind
of dedication some universes offer
before the curtains are even pulled back
Duncan Jones the award-winning filmmaker
behind moon said World of Warcraft's
immersive universe is what first
attracted him to sci-fi and fantasy as a
kid just as Star Wars inspired
innovative genre filmmakers of the past
few decades when they were kids
the innovative filmmakers are today and
tomorrow likely spent some time becoming
the world's first super power in total
war Rome - defeating the combine of
half-life 2 or slaying dragons and
Skyrim at the peak of their creative
development in short we're at the stage
where people making these moves are the
ones who grew up with the medium when it
sees to simply be distracting hobbies
and truly became a respectable art form
of storytelling platform Nintendo has
announced it has sold its 1 billionth
video game cartridge 211 million
Americans play video games it's also
surprising more diverse than people
would imagine women 18 or older
represent a significant portion of the
game playing population than boys 17 a
video game intellectual properties such
as Mario and gran turismo also have just
as much global appeal as comic books
it's especially popular in countries
that make up a majority of foreign box
office grosses China in particular can
be a game changer for studios this year
they lifted their government-issue ban
on game consoles China has already been
interested in computer games their
market for video games is now running
parallel with the growth of their
growing
on average ten new movie theaters are
being constructed every day in China
it's estimated that by 2015 it will
surpass North America as a primary
box-office research is a concern you as
the game business now gotten to the
movie business and the pop music
business not in my opinion so when and
what is the next step what will be the
project that finally breaks the quality
curse with the video game adaptation
there are a number of films and
development Sony is gearing up to
conclude Paul W Anderson's Resident Evil
series and Breaking Bad's Aaron Paul is
hitting the road looking to attract the
Fast and Furious crowd what they need
for speed title perhaps nothing is
getting us quite as excited as legendary
adaptational water Warcraft directed by
you guessed it Duncan Jones if I were a
betting man I'd say it has a good chance
of being fresh but in our opinion there
are a number of games that can make
excellent limits